yo yo yo rejectos we're gonna watch
spider-man three no way home
leaks how villains are alive again oh
this is coming from our homie very very
very close friend of mine warren from
the cosmic
the wonder knot let's do this people
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some pretty big
spider-man leaks and they're different
than we've really had before
in the fact that they actually describe
why some things that are going to happen
in spider-man no way home are actually
happening specifically in regards to
not just the main villain but the other
villains as well because as most
everybody knows there have been
a lot of villains reported and rumored
to be in this movie
it's almost going to be an unofficial
sinister six or an official sinister six
if they decide to
call them or like a sinister three other
villains
are coming into the mcu after dying
this plot leak does a pretty good job of
explaining and it also does a pretty
good job
this is how they still want to kill
peter parker
so these are multiple leaks compiled
together by somebody who the internet
seemingly trusts right now they're
coming from
reddit user spideyforever245 so as usual
i'll go over
all of the leaks first and then we'll
talk about why do they trust him
specifically
super reputable sounding name
subscribe to me and cosmic culture link
in the description down below the
giveaway ends at the end of this month
so these leaks are all taken from the
same thread but the person who posted
these leaks kind of did a q a
where people asked him a little bit
about the film and he answered some
questions
so we'll just go in order of how we gave
information the first thing he says
is that there is going to be a rematch
between toby mcguire spider-man
there has to be there has to be
spider-man movies
they are retconning doc ock to go insane
again
with the arms but they're also going to
take a sympathetic
angle with him which kind of makes sense
because the last time yes yes yes
if he is from the same ramen universe
which they go on to answer later he just
lost his wife
now this leaker did say that he's not
sure exactly where toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man get taken
from their movie like what point in time
but of course they do get taken from
their respective universes and brought
into the main
mcu however it does say that willem
dafoe's green goblin
will be in the movie from the sam raimi
universe
first off i really do love the idea this
is describing the sleep they're saying
they're going to get a
sympathetic approach for doc och again i
don't want him to go
full-on villain essentially if you're
doing dr octopus he's a full-on villain
however
this is doc from the raimi verse i
wanted to you know still carry that
thread
but if they do find a way to cleverly
justify his descent
back into full-on villain i'd be down
for it yeah if you could go there once
he could go there again
yeah especially after such a weird turn
of events as multiversal travel but them
having a rematch
it's pretty hard to top that whole
sequence that led up to the train fight
in spider-man 2
and while i think john watts has action
improved a lot and far from home i'm
like i don't know if you could top the
redmi
action though and if you're going to do
a rematch you got to try to top it right
or at least match it in some way you got
to try i'm still sure it'd be freaking
awesome regardless and recently there
was another report from daniel rpk that
stated that willem dafoe's green goblin
will be the main villain of this film
and i know a lot of people are asking
how since he died in the very first sam
raimi spider-man
stabbed in the next today we actually
kind of have an answer for that
the leak says that the villains are
brought back from the dead
but not really he goes on to explain
that at the split second between
life and death the villains were pulled
from their home worlds and
into the mcu so they remember dying
and are essentially dead in a sense so
this will apply to norman osborne the
green goblin
dock and electro and alfred molina
did come out in a very public interview
and stated that john watts told him that
they're going to pick up
with his character where they left off
in that final scene where he's sinking
into the water
okay wait a minute so it's like it's
right before like the split second
right before they die so like right as
willem dafoe is like crumbling over onto
the glider right as uh dr octavius is
sinking with the collapsing star and
then right as electro how did he go out
but that would still
undo green goblin yeah because then it's
like peter would just be standing there
and he would disappear
yeah you wouldn't get spiderman
yeah yeah then how would you get all
this stuff with doctor octavia because
doesn't spiderman return the body
to will yeah he brings it back and harry
sees it
yeah that's part of what builds like the
defining okay
all right this leak starting to lose me
yeah a little bit and with electro
so-called death it kind of looks like he
could have actually been teleported
somewhere else
goblin's the most questionable one
that's the other thing
killed off screen and remembers his
death it's fair to note that this could
be from a different universe and he said
what happened to sandman
applies to the rhino and the lizard
meaning they could be in the movie
however he doesn't specifically say for
sure
that they are in the movie but with so
many villains cool to elude at least
definitely doesn't surprise me at all
now it goes on to say that the reason
that these villains hate spider-man in
this movie and are going to try and kill
him
is because they actually remember
spider-man as the one who tried to kill
them or
actually did kind of kill them so that's
why all of the villains are probably
originally going to be going after
i love that photo his head just looks
way too small for that body
it's okay the lighting is dramatic
though it's such a perfect cut out of
his head
he's just slapping a bigger guy's body
so that's why all of the villains are
probably originally going to be going
after tom holland spider-man and then
the other two andrew and toby
are going to show up and help because
it's kind of their fault too and then he
goes on to say that he believes that
wanda is the one who so-called breaks
the multiverse and causes the multiverse
trouble to happen
now we know that one division spiderman
no way home and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness are kind of
like a three-part movie not really as
far as the actual story of each
individual project
is concerned but simply the effect that
they're going to have
on the mcu and the universe or
multiverse like you're
saying spoiler alert if you haven't seen
the ending of one division
at the end of juan division wanda gets
the dark hold
now for those who may not know what the
dark hold is it's an insanely ancient
and
evil book of spells sometimes referred
to as the book of
sins it was actually written by the
ancient elder demon god
was banished and it was kind of good for
him to get back into
the earth dimension so we can see how
this book
could cause some serious multiverse
issues after all one of its main
purposes
is to get an elder demon god from one
different reality to
another i don't know how much the dark
cold what all
entails but maybe with willem dafoe
cause i believe willem dafoe was in this
100
100 believe it i'm not disputing that
and if i see the movie and he's not i
won't accept it
will the darkhold be something that does
factor in as a way to resurrect people i
don't know i feel like the dark has the
capability of doing that absolutely yeah
if anything can do it usually it's the
darkness yeah and not to mention we did
have that
nexus commercial in one division which
could be implying that wanda is
a nexus being now a nexus in the marvel
universe
act as the keystones of the multiverse
and are crucial to its ultimate
coherence and stability
in fact typically nexus beings are
watched over by cosmic forces such as
the time variance authority which we are
going to see
in loki nexus beans can affect
probability
and thus the future altering the flow of
the universal time stream
and in one division agatha did mention
that wanda did a probability hex
although wanda
didn't really know what she was talking
about maybe it wasn't a hex but simply
the fact that she was a nexus bean
and if she is all of this tampering with
the dark hole that she's doing could
definitely affect the multiverse and
that could cause some pretty big
problems for our friendly neighborhood
spider-man and this could actually
explain why doctor strange is in
spider-man no way home
i mean if we're being honest that was
kind of the first dead giveaway
of the multiverse or spider-verse in
nowhere home when doctor strange was
confirmed to be in the very true
why else would he be there he's not
really the role model father figure type
like tony stark was to peter he's more
of the
i have to protect your reality douchebag
type so what this week
actually does tell us is how some of
these dead characters
can return yes exactly it's a good way
to put good jokes
nice seeing your humor shine through but
yeah i mean especially with feige coming
out and confirming
doctor strange was in fact supposed to
be in one division
and that the commercials were done by
orchestrated by him so yeah like i love
the point that you're making about how
they are sort of like a trilogy of
stories i feel like the tva will play a
factor into this in some way the events
of a loki but
but they've really had us focus
specifically on wanda vision doctor
transported versus madness and
spider-man no way home you make a solid
point there about yeah doctor strange is
the biggest giveaway of it of all
yeah it's almost like going one step
further off of
far from home and going and you had the
whole like you know
alluded to illusion of the multiverse
and now
the real guy who has to look over that
stuff is gonna have to come into the
next one and deal with the real
thing they aren't actually dead they
were taken right before death
right before that very last inch of life
was taken from them
because at this time there have been
several reports stating that willem
dafoe's green goblin is indeed going to
be the main villain
and he's going to be from the sam raimi
universe but
how if he died in the very first film
and then alfred molina's dog ock died in
the second sam remy film
and then of course elektro died in the
amazing spider-man 2.
and i also think it's safe to say that
while these villains are being taken
from their respective universes
their spider-man are being taken as well
and that's how they all
end up in rmc or spider-man he was taken
and that explains why these characters
would be attacking
aunt may has a very particular set of
skills they think he
killed them because let's be honest a
spider-man suit is kind of a spider-man
suit in the eyes of the villains they
see a spider-man suit they see
spider-man they want to kill him
but luckily he'll have some help from
some old seasoned veterans
now as far as this leak is concerned i
think it does a pretty good job at
answering some of the questions
about how some of the characters get to
our universe especially after being dead
as with all leaks you should take them
with a grain of salt but this
is really in line with everything that
we've heard so far the villains seem to
be the same and obviously line up
obviously the spider-verse slash
multiverse is the same and how the
villains do get into
the mcu does line up with what alfred
molina did say
in his interview his character was going
to be taken from
and pick up where they left off in that
final moment
well how do you pick up from a final
moment right before death
you send them into another universe so
let me know what you think about these
leaks or if they just die upon a ride
you can get on board with sure it's all
mumbo jumbo
it's all all easy ways to justify i'm
even sitting here going well maybe
the rainy verse is just like it's the
first time it happened
and then you know maybe due to some kind
of inter-dimensional yeah mumbo jumbo
it'll just be like oh yeah all that
stuff did happen but now they're being
plucked individually off a new timeline
or something i don't know either way
great queer video warren really liked
the way you've been developing your
commentary lately
uh really good job great job great great
great great
job you're a good man there warren
turned on right now you're a good lad
uh we are going to end the video now
so hey subscribe to coach recorder
subscribe to real rejects
click that notification bell hit that
like button but we can't end a video
without doing a
jean jeter jean what i want to see did
ever make a joke about him doing like a
multiverse of all the models and then
i think i'm having to like i think you
should make it just make a giant like
photograph session together where jean
gets to get all the other genes from his
other multiverses
oh man think of all the possibilities
you could do gene
time around all the time the world will
be just one
giant explosion orgasm yeah
all because there's one photo right when
you think that all the models are too
tired what do you hear
gene on your left more models show up
and then you get the biggest picture
everyone in new york is in
it it's gonna be the best
check out gene's channel and his
instagram page guys
it's worth it